years ago in 2011 footage of the first
Dark Souls demo surfaced out of e3 media
could play as a soldier a knight a witch
a Pyromancer a Black Knight but most
memorable for me as solaire of astora
and so seven years later in our first
demo of Dark Souls remastered I
immediately set out to recover Celeste
gear and playthrough in exactly the same
way you might want to look away real
quick but this is also as far as media
was allowed to go in this remaster so as
my overburdened Celaya cosplayer with 12
endurance legs his gear back to fire
link let's compare these visuals to the
original starting with this IV growing
on the ramparts so it's animated in the
remaster and Static in the original and
once I noticed this a wealth of little
details now started to stand out the
grass at fire link now sways in the
breeze fire gives off smoked fog gates
are far more detailed blood has a new
particle effect and death as you
dissipate into a much denser grey mist
as a result of all this animation and
all these particle effects the world
feels way more lively although it's not
like they've updated the entire world
they haven't gone over it with a
fine-tooth comb
because there are still some buggy or
missing textures if you know where to
look and I found a couple of textures
that really should have been subtly
animated but weren't if you've got a
good eye at this point you'll have
realized that the most impressive
changes have to do with the lighting in
this side-by-side you can probably
easily note how much better the remaster
handles light emitting from the bonfire
and reflecting on a shield here and
notice how the shadows from my AMA set
and the shadow it casts upon itself
they're way more defined
the original game by comparison looks
harsh and unrealistic as if the entire
world is lit from every angle and the
world isn't really reacting dynamically
to light or shadow so Dark Souls
remastered it's gonna look good to new
players getting into the series for the
first time I don't think it'll show its
age too much anymore but new players
that's exactly who it's designed for
because as you can probably tell by now
there certainly aren't many gameplay
changes that are intended to lower old
players back I've tested everything I
can think of and the changes to the
gameplay that I've noticed
mostly quality of life changes for
example one of the best changes is that
you can now scale down the UI which
makes the game way more cinematic this
was one of the best features of dsfix on
PC and if you having trouble finding
your Estus when you shrink these
tooltips down don't worry because
they've added that ability to skip to
the first item in your quick slot bar by
holding down on the d-pad so in most
cases this just brings you immediately
to your Estus flask next if you want to
consume more than one soul or humanity
at a time you now have that option you
can even rebind all your controls if you
so desire which is really rare on
console but definitely a welcome change
and lastly it seems as if we now have
the ability to switch covenants at the
bonfire and unless there's hidden stuff
later in the game these are the only
gameplay changes to dark souls
remastered leading up to this remaster I
had two sets of expectations I had one
set of really admittedly unreasonable
expectations like the remaster having
Dark Souls threes combat new enemies new
items or new areas just new content
basically that's unreasonable but I also
did have what I thought were pretty
reasonable expectations considering how
easy they would be
to implement and how big of an effect
they would have on returning veteran
players like being able to roll in any
direction while locked on or even run
while locked on was a hugely positive
combat change for all Soul sequels I
thought that items might have been moved
around or I thought that items might at
least have a few different stats but so
far I can confirm that none of those
changes are in the game and as a result
it's pretty clear finally that Dark
Souls remastered makes no development
effort to lure old veteran players back
so if you've already purchased the
original game there's really not that
much different here and to be completely
fair they were never aiming for that
demographic and that's fine we just
didn't know until now because putting
aside my bias and my personal
disappointment I'm still happy for the
millions of people who started the
series at Dark Souls 2 or Dark Souls 3
or even blood-borne and those people are
in the millions there's a lot of people
who haven't played Dark Souls 1 and
there's a ton of new players that are
going to come to this game from Nintendo
switch and they'll all be getting the
exact same experience we did in Dark
Souls 1 without the excruciating pain of
having to offer one humanity at a time
to the fair lady
so are these changes enough for you to
purchase Dark Souls remastered and play
it again I'm really curious to hear your
responses because personally I'm looking
forward to a world full to the brim with
new players and I'm looking forward to
all those twitch streams that will push
this to the top of the charts for a week
or so and we might as well ride that
wave of hype red eye orb in hand ready
to show all these new players what Dark
Souls is all about also I plan on
private streaming this to patrons when
it comes out because it coincides nicely
with me finally getting good internet
I'm still in the process of setting up
my stream which is why I kind of want a
small audience while I figure it out I
think if all you guys came in at once
you would just intimidated of me
I never really got used to how many of
you guys there are and it's one thing to
get like a million views on a YouTube
video and it's another thing entirely to
have a thousand of you and live twitch
chat talking at me at once
a scary map so if you're a patron I'll
see you on stream in a week or so and if
you're not I'll see you all on stream
eventually regardless and I'll see you
all in the next video which is most
likely about the great Wars of Dark
Souls
so until then guys
you
[Music]